what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Lauren Thompson
and today we have quite a bit of
Spider-Man news and yes some of it is
about Spider-Man 4 in the MCU with Tom
Holland but some is about other
Spider-Man properties that are going to
be taking place outside of the MCU and
it looks like we could be getting an
official announcement from Sony very
very soon specifically in regards to
Spider-Man 4 5 and 6 now this is already
confirmed we already know there's going
to be another spider Man trilogy with
Tom Holland insiders have told us that
Tom Holland has signed a new deal with
Sony and Marvel to appear in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as Spider-Man and
based off of what some insiders have
said we know that he has signed up for
six more projects three of them are
going to be Spider-Man movies and the
others are going to be teamup films so
of course Avengers King Dynasty Secret
Wars and maybe Daredevil the third one
is unclear at this point in time but
there are talks of a West Coast Avengers
movie possibly happening before the King
Dynasty so that could be it as well
bottom line Spider-Man is coming back
and it seems like Tom Holland of course
is going to be Peter Parker Spider-Man
again however it does seem like this may
be his last time playing Spider-Man
which is totally understandable that is
a lot of movies to play Spider-Man and
the Spider-Man homecoming Trilogy plus
all of the other ones like the Avengers
and Captain America Civil War plus now
six new projects three of them are his
very own that's a really long time to
play Spider-Man but of course we also
glad that he got to and gets to do all
of this but it looks like Spider-Man 4
is going to start to usher in a new
Spider-Man and that new Spider-Man is
somebody I think a lot of people are
really wanting to make his MCU debut and
of course we are talking about Miles
Morales now first things first Miles
Morales should exist in the MCU as it is
already if we think back to Spider-Man
homecoming we met Donald Glover's
character who is the uncle of Miles
Morales the prowler I'm sure most people
remember he even said he has a nephew
that lives around here and that nephew
of course is Miles Morales now sometimes
Marvel Studios plans way in advance and
this could have been a setup for Miles
Morales way back then or it could have
just been a fun little Easter egg but
either way it does seem like he is
coming and we have a new report today
from the account film Odyssey who has
been accurate with reports in the past
and this is what they tweeted out
recently as it's been mentioned Miles
Morales will be in Spider-Man 4 he won't
be the same age as Peter he'll be
younger a little bit of time will have
passed since Spider-Man no way home from
what I can tell no word on if Donald
Glover will be returning as his uncle
will have to see now I really do hope
they bring back Donald Glover for this
at least a slight Cameo after all he did
sign up to do a Spider-Man project
recently actually getting his own film
in the Sony Spider-Man universe playing
the villain Hypno Hustler so a
completely different character
altogether but this exists in the Sony
Spider-Man universe not in the the MCU
so he still could show up in the MCU he
could still play Aaron Davis Prowler so
fingers crossed there but bottom line
Miles Morales should be making his MCU
debut in Spider-Man 4 and if this is
true if this comes to fruition that
probably means that he is going to be
our next Spider-Man after Tom Holland
leaves which I am all for I really hope
we get live adaptations for both Miles
Morales and Gwen Stacy two iconic
characters and I can't wait to see both
in the MCU but as far as Miles Morales
is concerned it does look like we are
going to go down the path of Spider-Man
Peter Parker Spider-Man that is
mentoring him and over the course of the
three new Spider-Man movies not the
Avengers films but just the Spider-Man
movies we'll see miles start off as a
younger kid but over the years over the
movies he'll grow up and I think
eventually he will take over the
Spider-Man character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe once Tom Holland
exits leaving us after the three
Spider-Man movies with a new Spider-Man
and a completely new trajectory and
story for the character which I'm all
for and I think a lot of fans are really
for as well now as far as how Miles
Morales is going to kind of enter the
story in Spider-Man 4 I'm going to say
it's going to connect to Feast Aunt May
in the last Spider-Man film seemed to be
running Feast like she does in the
comics and guess who was known to
volunteer at Feast Miles Morales now
since Aunt May is now gone rest in peace
our Peter Parker might want to go to Fe
feast and volunteer of course Peter is
going to be missing Aunt May I'm sure
and Spider-Man 4 so it would make sense
that he would go and volunteer at Feast
since that's something that she loved to
do working at feast and helping people
so this could be how Miles Morales and
Peter Parker meet both volunteering at
feast and if they both have a spider
sense or a Peter tingle as Peter calls
it in the MCU perhaps they'll kind of
have some sort of a connection and kind
of catch on to each other and know that
hey something's kind of similar about
the two of us and and either they figure
it out or maybe miles kind of gets a
hunch and he follows Peter around and
realizes that hey this guy's Spider-Man
either way I think it's going to be cool
to have miles in the MCU and I think
Feast might be that connection that puts
the two of them together and eventually
has them figure out that they are both
spider people so hopefully this is true
and miles is coming in Spider-Man 4 and
as far as the official announcement like
I talked about it is confirmed that Sony
is going to be attending cinemacon on
April 24th their panel is at 6:15 PST
apparently they are going to be having a
presentation and we could be getting
Spider-Man 4 news also Venom 3 news and
maybe a craven the hunter in Madame web
trailer now as far as the Spider-Man 4
announcement is concerned I'm actually
expecting we'll get an announcement
about a new Trilogy basically Sony going
hey we are indeed making Spider-Man 4 5
and six maybe kind of give us a name of
the trilogy but perhaps not any official
names for the movie now when they
announced announced the homecoming
Trilogy at first they did announce that
it was going to be three different
movies but of course we didn't get the
titles for the three movies they make us
wait for those they really really make
us wait for those and right now the
rumored release date for Spider-Man 4 in
the MCU not confirmed but the rumored
release date is July of 2024 this
presentation is going to take place in
April which is going to be more than a
year before Spider-Man 4 would come out
so I'm not sure if they would actually
release the title yet typically Sony
releas releases the title about 10
months before but cinemacon will be
about 15 months before Spider-Man 4's
alleged release date so maybe not a
title but an announcement that the new
Trilogy with Tom Holland is coming and
then of course I am expecting something
about Venom 3 and last but not least in
the Spider-Man news today there is a
liveaction Spider-Man series in the
works at Amazon and it is going to be
about Spider-Man Noir now this isn't the
first time that Sony is doing a
Spider-Man project outside of Sony and
Marvel of course but here's what the
article from variety has to tell us
about what to expect from the show it
says the Untitled series will follow an
older grizzled superhero in 1930s New
York City an individual with knowledge
of the project says that the show will
be set in its own universe and the main
character will not be Peter Parker and
everybody is already saying at this
point it better be Nicholas Cage now you
don't really see his face that much so
I'm kind of okay with that but the
important thing to note here is that
this is not going to connect to Sony's
Spider-Man universe Sony is building a
big spiderverse right now and they have
a lot of different moving Parts Madame
Webb is supposed to be kind of a
Multiverse film explaining the
spiderverse and then of course we have
other films coming up like Craven the
Hunter and Venom 3 is supposed to have
another Spider-Man in that film that is
not Tom Holland Spider-Man so a lot of
people are wondering what's going on
there but this film about Spider-Man
Noir will not be a part of that Universe
it will be a one-off project not
connecting to anything but still
interesting nonetheless I would really
like to see a Spider-Man Noir liveaction
series but of course I'm also looking
forward to Spider-Man in the MCU and
looking forward to seeing what Sony's
going to do with their Spider-Man
universe so let me know what you are
most excited about in the comments down
below let me know what you think about
Miles Morales joining Spider-Man 4 and
what you hope to see from that don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date on the latest
Spider-Man news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof